have you heard about this no alternative
to credit cards that's allowing them to
get paid anywhere between 17 to 70%
annually and avoid going through the
truth in Lending Act that came out to
protect consumers from being destroyed
by credit card have you heard about this
new thing it's called buy now pay later
guess who's using it airm claro Apple
PayPal and you're making so much money
and so attracted to the consumer because
the consumer says babe this thing here
is 1,000 bucks I can't pay th000 right
now but guess what this buy not pay
later allows me to pay only 25% right
now which is $250 and I get to pay the
other in three payments 250 250 250 over
the next 6 weeks and I own it in a many
cases this is 0% how cool is this then
how do they make their money well these
companies like Clara on the back end get
paid 2 to 8% from the person that's
selling the product so for example Apple
would send Clara this is a $1,000
product hey will give you $20 to $80 so
that's how they're making their money
couple different ways but God forit if
you make miss a payment it goes to 30%
and by the way more than 4 in 10
Americans who have taken out one of
these buy up pay P later loans have made
a payment late on one of those loans
according to a new survey from Lending
Tree which is why 23% of BMP customers
have regretted financing a purchase this
way so why are people using it I don't
know babe it's a hot phenomenon they're
making a lot of money let alone on top
of this credit card companies today just
increase their rates it's the highest
it's ever been $3.57 trillion of
available credit do you know Banks the
largest banks in America rais limits on
18.4 million credit cards inica America
in the first quarter of this year it's
up 22% why are they doing this making a
lot of money and then on top of that
they open a record-breaking $89 billion
worth of new credit card accounts in the
first quarter of 2023 all because
interest rates are increasing and
they're finding another way to make
money I got so much stuff to share with
you here right now but this is
concerning for me I've been in debt
before and there are some quotes about
debt I want to read you and we'll get
into the episode first one is he who is
quick to borrow is slow to pay you know
how I know that I've been quick to
borrow many many times in my early 20s
here's the next one for you if you think
nobody cares if you're alive try missing
a couple of car payments orl Wilson they
will call you and they will get their
money and last but not least which is
the heaviest one Andrew Jackson when you
get in debt you become a slave these
companies are producing a lot of slaves
today if you get value out of this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel so let's get into it if this is
such a weird thing why are people doing
it well because listen companies want
you to spend money the government wants
you to spend money that's how GDP goes
up the more money you spend the better
it is companies are making money do you
think people are waking up in the
morning saying let me find a way to
prevent you from getting into debt no
they own you it's like a drug dealer get
addicted spend the money get addicted I
buy I make more money get addicted to
this video game buy another nftd buy
another this the more you get addicted
the more money I'm going to be making
fine that's okay no problem you make a
very good movie maybe I'm I'm addicted
to it you make a very good book I'm
addicted to reading it fine we can talk
about that but you as an individual have
to make a choice so you don't fall for
this trap because it's very stressful I
remember being in Deb $49,000 my credit
score being 484 495 $499 something
happens to men when you're in debt you
can't lead better you can't be a good
father husband your your temper is short
your feuds are short you're irritated
with people around you because you're in
debt and you don't know how to pay for
it you follow BK do you not follow BK
it's very stressful so watch this 70% of
America's GDP is generated from consumer
spending
70% of the GDP is stemmed from you
spending money with interest rates at 5%
and a much higher cost of living
consumers are getting squeezed personal
saving rates are near record low levels
when you look at this chart we are not
saving a lot of money but damn we're
spending a lot of money right now so
then the question becomes you'll hear
our politicians saying look at the GDP
growing it's been the best growth of GDP
we've had in the last seven quarters
it's amazing it's record-breaking look
at this chart right here Q3 202 3 GDP
grew by 4.9% how because you're
contributing towards it you're spending
money and you know what the President
says on behalf of the White House I just
want to say thank you for your spending
money whether it's buy out pay later
credit cards you're helping us have very
good number thank you so much for
spending money by the way that's kind of
like in MBS you know Saudi Arabia 42%
their GDP comes from oil you consumers
are oil to the US economy so let's take
a look at some of this data from buy now
pay later the market for buy now pay
later so I'm call it bmpl and
alternative to credit cards whose
popularity exploded during the pandemic
is expected to reach $4 trillion in 2030
consumers are taking advantage of ways
to pay for goods and services in
interest free installments Markel
advisers estimates the total number of
bmpl users will exceed 1 and A5 billion
by 2030 from 43 million in the first
half of
2023 that's nearly 4X in 7 years and by
the way if you're wondering how it was
this last Christmas here's what it looks
like Dear Santa can I pay later this
year 2021 bmpl 12.8 billion 2022 14.5
billion 2023 17 billion if you want to
know a little bit deeper What ethnicity
and background uses this the most whites
only 16% Hispanics 24 blacks 26% and if
you were to take a wild guess which
household income you think uses as more
over 75,000 or under 75,000 I'm sure you
got this one right 73% of those under
75,00 000 use this
17.6% only use it above $775,000 and
watch this age category 18 to 24 42% 25
to 34 50% 35 to 44 50% 45 to 54 33 55
plus 19% so if you're like me you're
wonder why are people even using this
these are the top reasons why people use
it number one easier to make payments
two flexibility lower interest rates
easy approval process it's a soft credit
check is what they call it credit card
are maxed out out no interest low credit
card limit now if you're wondering what
they're spending it on here's a chart to
tell you what they're spending on
according to Lending Tree clothing buy a
mile at the top technology items then
shoes home decor furniture accessories
beauty products jewelry sporting or
fitness equipment toys travel books
event tickets and other and the most
popular bmpl compan is being used right
now at the top is Paypal then it's
afterpay then Clara then airm then zip
and sizzled and split it in another and
as of October 2023 Apple has officially
launched this for us residents
congratulations folks so the question
becomes so if you miss a payment if it's
not if they're not following the
guidelines of truth and lending act
there's no way they can report to your
credit if you miss a payment right
here's what happens consequences of
missing a buying out pay later uh
payment charging interest on the unpaid
balance turning over your account to a
collection agency damage credit score
not allowing you to make future
purchases with the plan so your credit
score we'll take a hit okay so final
thoughts look I want I want to kind of
get you thinking here as the consumer
cuz this is what this did to me when I'm
thinking about it we got three parties
involved right the first party is what
the consumer oh this is great 25% up
front 25 25 25 how awesome is it I just
bought a $1,000 thing for $ 250 I like
this okay then it's the buy out pay
lader companies that are charging the
service they're in the middle and then
there's the company that's selling the
product guess who likes this program the
most if we were to rank it guess who
likes the most these guys who has the
least risk these guys I sold the product
I got my money yeah I gave this guy in
the middle 2 to 8% I don't care product
was 100 bucks I give you $2 to $8 cool
go collect the debt I don't need to
collect the debt that's your job to do
so these guys have the least amount of
risk okay these guys have a lot of risk
cuz they may not get the money back and
then these guys have risk as well so but
I understand the Dynamics between the
three that's bmpl stuff it's another
creative way of getting money from the
consumer putting you into that and
getting you to pay for they're going to
end up getting their money Apple's going
to get their money you know why okay go
ahead and go make the payment go be late
on the payment you know what Apple can
turn off called this right here
smartphone PayPal go ahead and don't
make the payment you can no longer bid
on eBay no I got to be able to bid on
eBay they have controls to do this
smaller companies you may not need Clara
or aform or all these other guys but I'm
not a fan of uh uh this at all I've been
in debt before it sucks I just want to
talk to you while you're watching this
if you're still around with us CU this
is not a very exciting topic it's debt
who the hell wants to talk about credit
card debt and buy I pay later you would
much rather go buy the clothes and show
the Louis purse you got or the nice
phone you got here's what I will tell
you being in debt sucks you are a slave
you can't sleep it affects the way you
parent it affects the way you treat your
spouse it affects the way you are as a
son or a daughter it affects the way you
are as an employee it affects the way
you are as a friend it affects your
dreams your life your peace your
happiness prevent yourself from being
tempted for financing things you
shouldn't be buying in the first place
and increase your cash and go on a
credit card or buy not pay later diet
for 10 years and see if you can do that
see what it'll do to you it'll be one of
the best decisions you ever make in your
life if you can resist from this
Temptation that they're selling
your way anyways Mike asked me a good
question says Pat isn't this an example
of bad capitalist I said not at all he
said what do you mean these guys are
making billions of dollars ripping
clients up I said no the consumer's at
fault why are you buying it why are you
falling for it he say I'm a bartender
you come to my bar and I'm a sick
bartender which means what how you doing
how's everything Johnny wife is good
tell me about your day today bad day
today really what happened what happened
at work no way here you want another one
you want another one you man I'm so
sorry to hear hour and a half later I
got you drunk and you Bild is 140 bucks
you tipped me 40 bucks I'm a great
bartender but you had 1,000 bucks in the
bank you just gave me 20% of your
savings you should have never come to
the bar so what am I the bad guy no the
consumer is you got to control your
decisions we you and I and this if you
notice I'm getting emotional because I
was here just 23 years ago I'm 45 at 22
23 I was addicted to credit cards and
getting myself in a bad situation
anyways if you got value yet of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to this channel by the way if you've
never watch an old school video I did
which it applies any time of the day cuz
it's Evergreen go watch 20 rules of
money these 20 rules is why I have a
couple dollars today take care everybody
bye-bye